ter grresselzeit ist immer wieder ein
Stichwort in diesem Krieg sie sagen
Putin hätte ein Interesse daran auf
einen möglichst langen Krieg zu setzen
und er weniger auf schnelle Erfolge
warum genau wählt Putin ihrer Meinung
nach diese Taktik was bringt sie zu der
Annahme die hat er im Grunde im April
letzten Jahres eingeschlagen damals
wurde klar dass eine schnelle
Niederwerfung der Ukraine und
Austauschen der Regierung nicht im
Bereich der Möglichkeiten der russischen
Armee war man stand zwar im im Norden
und man stand im Osten Kiev aber man war
heilos überdehnt man konnte die
Hauptstadt nicht einnehmen man hatte die
Truppen nicht dazu andererseits ist
Russland von seinen Maximalforderungen
die Putin in seiner Rede zur
Kriegserklärung oder de facto
Kriegserklärung zu Beginn der
spezialoperation genannt hat nie
abgerückt und das haben lavrov das haben
peskov das haben Putin in allen ihren
Reden und allen ihren Statements immer
wieder bekräftigt dass sie diesen Krieg
militärisch entscheiden wollen wie hat
man da seit ab Krieg geführt man hat in
der Ostukraine angefangen eine
Materialschlacht zu führen und diese
Materialschlacht führt man immer noch
und Putin in ein seiner letzten Besuche
bei der Rüstungsindustrie hat auch
gesagt wie viel leopardpanzer produziert
denn die Ukraine wie viel Patriot
produziert denn die Ukraine also man
weiß in Russland natürlich dass die
Ukraine von internationaler
Unterstützung abhängig ist wenn man die
ukrainische Armee nicht schnell schlagen
kann wenn man die ukrainische
Bevölkerung nicht schnell einschüchtern
kann dann kann man doch über die Jahre
hinaus die Kosten für diesen Krieg so
hoch treiben dass der Westen irgendwann
sagt wir haben genug wir gehen da raus
das war Putins
auch Putins persönliches Erlebnis gerade
mit vielen amerikanischen Präsidenten er
hat den Abzug aus dem Irak miterlebt der
hat vor diesem Krieg den Abzug der
Amerikaner aus Afghanistan miterlebt und
es ist seine Erfahrung mit dem Westen
wenn der Krieg zu lang dauert und wenn
die Kosten zu hoch werden äh dann
schmeißen die Westler das Handtuch und
er hat ja noch berechtigte Hoffnung dass
Donald Trump äh
2024 antreten wird dass er könnte zum
Gewinnen es kann in der Kongresswahl
weiter zu Schwierigkeiten kommen wir
sehen ja jetzt auch die ganzen Probleme
um die Nominierung eines speakers die
Budgetdebatte in den USA alles das macht
die Hilfe für die Ukraine schwierig und
das bestärkt natürlich auch Putin in
seiner Haltung dass es mit Fortdauer des
Krieges äh leichter wird für ihn noch
dazu wir haben es ja im vorigen Beitrag
gesehen Angriff auf die
Energieinfrastruktur wir haben im Sommer
gesehen der Angriff auf Getreide
Infrastruktur Getreide
landwirtschaftliche Produkte und
elektrischer Strom waren die beiden
großen Exportgüter der Ukraine nach
Beginn des Krieges für beides kriegt man
einen guten Weltmarktpreis kriegt die
Wiesen und dementsprechend schaffen die
auch Arbeit
beides versucht Russland
schwergewichtsmäßig anzugreifen und auch
auszuschalten weil damit die
Abhängigkeit der Ukraine auch finanziell
vom Westen steigt alles was die Ukraine
nicht mehr selber zahlen kann jede
Granate muss von irgendjemanden anderen
bezahlt werden die Leute in der
Rüstungsindustrie arbeiten ja auch nicht
umsonst und sind auch nicht die Caritas
das heißt hier versucht Russland auch
ganz gezielt die Last für diesen Krieg
von der Ukraine auf den Westen
umzuschultern und hat dann eben mit den
Wahlen in der Slowakei mit den
Schwierigkeiten in den USA mit
Zerwürfnis sogar mit engem Verbündeten
Polen im im polnischen Wahlkampf
die Hoffnung dass diese Zerwürfnisse
dass die Ausdauer im Westen hier
einbricht das ist die gegenwärtige
Strategie das ist auch der Grund warum
Putin nicht von seinen maximalen
Kriegszielen abrückt er hat zurzeit
keinen Grund von diesen abzurücken er
hat zurzeit keinen Grund auf irgendeinen
Waffenstillstand einzugehen weil er sich
ausrechnet dass
wenn ein Präsident Trump wieder ins am
kommt der Deal für ihn besser wird und
solange zumindest nicht sicher weiß dass
das nicht ist wird dieser Krieg
fortgesetzt das heißt wir reden von
einem Krieg der zumindest bis zur
amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl im
November läuft und wahrscheinlich
am ersten oder am frühesten Mitte 2025
zu einer reevaluierung der Kriegsziele
in Russland führen will und frühestens
dann wird man in Moskau vielleicht zu
Verhandlung bereitin wir bekommen jede
Menge Zuschauerfragen Herr gresse ich
versuch sie der Reihenfolge nach ab
zuarbeiten mit ihnen weil sie gerade
schon das Stichwort Donald Trump gesagt
haben fragt uns ein Zuschauer was
passiert genau wenn Trump wieder
gewwählt wird er wird sich ja sicher
nicht in die beiden aktuellen Krieger
einmischen die USA tragen einen enorm
eine enorm große Last bzw die Hauptlast
in der militärischen Versorgung der
Ukraine es gibt in der republikanischen
Partei inlusive Donald Trump selber
Stimmen die sagen diese
diese Ausgaben gehen auf Kosten der
amerikanischen Wirtschaft die können wir
uns nicht leisten die stellen wir ein
wenn die USA die militärische
Unterstützung der Ukraine einstellen
dann stellt sich die Frage was machen
die Europäer wenn ich mir anschaue wie
eng etwa Kanzler Scholz immer mit den
USA Schritt in Schritt gehen will muss
ich mir dann natürlich auch die Frage
stellen wie geht es dann mit der
deutschen Waffenlieferung weiter haben
die Europäer den Mum zu sagen okay das
ist aber unser Kontinent hier
und auf diesem Kontinent halten wir die
europäische sicherheitsordnung aufrecht
und wir lassen das Russland nicht
durchgehen und wir springen jetzt ein
oder
äh ziehen dann europäische Hauptstädte
auch den Schwanz ein und das Problem ist
die Ukraine Rüstungsgüter Munition
werden zu 85% importiert aus dem Ausland
aus dem Westen aus den USA oder aus
Europa wenn dieser Strang versi liegt
dann hat die ukrainische Armee ein
enormes Problem ich kann jetzt natürlich
nicht sagen was genau passiert was wenn
Donald Trump an die Macht kommt weil ich
nicht in sein Kopf reinschauen kann aber
nach seinen wortäußerungen zu diesem
Konflikt wäre das ein wäre das für die
Ukraine ein enorm negatives Ereignis und
wie gesagt ich vernehme derzeit auch
keine vernünftige Strategie oder Planung
aus den europäischen Hauptstädten wie
man mit so einem Fall umgehen sollte
oder könnte oder würde
Stichwort Material und Waffen da fragt
Fabian Meer welche Gründe gibt es dafür
dass Europa noch keine weitreichenden
Verträge mit der Rüstungsindustrie
abgeschlossen hat obwohl Putins
Strategie ein langwieriger
abnutzungskrieg sein wird
ja es g eigentlich da gute Neuigkeiten
aus Berlin
wir haben ja diese Woche die
deutsch-ukrainischen Handels und
industrietage gehabt zu denen der
Minister für strategische Industrie auch
der Premierminister der Ukraine
angerückt war und es gibt weitreichende
Verträge mit deutschen
Rüstungsunternehmen auch in der Ukraine
Werke aufzubauen das Problem ist das
dauertzeit bis in der Ukraine
dementsprechendes rüstungsgü vom Band
rollt dauert das Zeit weil das nicht auf
Sprung geht in Europa hätte man
natürlich auch die Maschinen anwerfen
können man hätte also z
z.B ein leopardpanzer dauert in der
Produktion 3 Jahre
wenn man größere Mengen bestellen würde
boris bistorius hat ja mal 120 anvisiert
das
Nachbestellung für für mögliche weitere
Lieferungen an die
Ukraine auch bei den Schützenpanzern wie
gesagt wenn man mehr auf einmal bestellt
dann verkürz kann man diese diese
Lieferzeiten etwas
verkürzen das Problem ist vor 20 Monaten
als dieser Krieg begann wenn man in
Diskussionen mit Politik und
Entscheidungsträgern äh diese Frage
aufgeworfen hat dann wurde einem gesagt
der Krieg dauert ja nicht so lange äh
wenn ich Schützenpanzer XY der 2 Jahre
dauert wenn ich den jetzt anfange zu
produzieren dann kriege ich den nicht in
die Ukraine
also das ist viel zu langfristig das
Problem ist wenn wir es damals nicht
gemacht haben haben wir die Fahrzeuge
jetzt nicht und wenn wir erst am Tag der
amerikanischen Präsidentenwahl anfangen
umzudenken und selber zu denken und
eigenständige Produktion hochzufahren
dann sind wir halt je nach rüstungsgut
in eineinhalb bis zwei Jahren dort wo
wir am Tag der Wahl hätten hinfallen
müssen und das ist das ewige Problem wir
haben Politiker die nicht entscheiden
wollen und auf der anderen Seite haben
wir eine industrielle Lage die eben sehr
frühe weitreichende und weitblickende
Entscheidungen erfordert und das geht
leider nicht vernünftig zusammen schauen
wir noch mal auf die russische Seite
beim Material Thomas kör fragt woher
kriegen die Russen überhaupt noch
hochentwickelte elektronischeau Teile da
gab's jetzt auch aktuelle Meldungen aus
Großbritannien dass Russland wohl
mutmaßlich von Nordkorea beliefert wird
was jetzt zumindest Munition angeht da
ist die Rede von 1000 Containern die da
wohl nach Russland gebracht werden das
wird von russischer Seite als unbelegt
abgewiesen aber wie wahrscheinlich
halten sie das dass Nordkorea da als
Verbündeter auftritt und Waffen nach
Russland jetzt liefert das ist sehr
wahrscheinlich also es gibt zum einem
mal diese festgestellten Eisenbahn und
Schiffsbewegungen zwischen Russland und
Nordkorea die eben angesprungen sind das
zweite es gibt zwischen Nordkorea und
Russland sehr weit zurückreichende
rüstungsbeziehungen Nordkorea verwendet
Waffen überwiegend aus sowjetischer
Produktion oder Provenienz bzw
Nachbauten von diesen Waffen die
auf Maschinen nachgebaut wurden die man
aus der ehemaligen Sowjetunion spricht
im heutigen Russland erhalten hat das
heißt diese Beziehung die früher zwar
unter dem Teppich passiert ist weil
Sanktionen und Ächtung Nordkoreas für
seantopenwaffenprogramm als als
ungebührend empfinden haben lassen sie
offen zu zelebrieren aber die gab es
früher auch und jetzt durch die
wechselseitigen Besuche Kim in Moskau
lavrov im pyang davor schougo in pyang
ist diese Beziehung natürlich gestiegen
bei den Hightech Teilen greift Russland
großteils auf westliche Fabrikate
zurück hier muss man auch sagen dass
Russland bis jetzt keine großen
Anstrengungen unternommen hat etwa viele
westliche elektronische Bauteile durch
chinesische zu ersetzen sondern setzt
auf schmugckel indem man Scheinfirmen
gründet in
Drittstaaten etwa der Türkei
zentralasiatischen Staaten aber auch
Hongkong und dann über diese
Scheinfirmen diese Geräte importiert und
das ist ein Katz und Mausspiel mit den
Nachrichtendiensten des Westens bzw
Weise mit den exportkontrollbehörden des
Westens wann immer die Ukraine eine
russische Rakete abschießt und wir äh
Überlebende Teile haben die man
analysieren kann dann sehen wir welche
Baulose das waren dann können wir
aufgrund der Baulose und der Baunummern
zurückverfolgen äh wo diese wann diese
Geräte exportiert wurden an wen die
exportiert wurden und dann eben die
entsprechende Scheinfirma auf eine
Blacklist setzen aber das ist leider
immer ein sehr äh reaktives handeln und
viele europäische Staaten muss man auch
sagen haben nicht die
nachrichtendienstliche Kapazitäten so
ein Fehlverhalten präventiv aufzuklären
das heißt in den entsprechenden
trickstaaten wirklich zu schauen was
diese Firmen machen die hier Teile
bestellen wo die sind äh und ob das mit
rechten Dingen zugehen wird oder nicht